catastrophe du décès du théâtre bien une
bombe qui a explosé à bord de l'appareil
la thèse de l'attentât est donc
confirmée liban les chrétiens ayant
renoncé à exiger le départ de l'armée
syriennes du pays un cessez le feu a pu
être proclamée des milliers de réfugiés
rentrent à beyrouth
s'accrochant à cette petite chance de
paix les français sont de plus en plus
nombreux à s'endetter trop lourdement le
gouvernement cherche le moyen de
protéger les consommateurs contre la
tentation du crédit pro facile et
parfois trompeurs enquête dans cette
édition là monsieur bonsoir
l'information principale de ce samedi
demeure l' enquête sur la catastrophe du
dc 10 d'uta le gouvernement a décidé
d'employer les grands moyens pour savoir
très vite ce qui s'est exactement passé
ce soir nous sommes en mesure d'affirmer
qu'il s'agissait bien d'un attentes
c'est une bombe placée à l'intérieur de
l'appareil qui a explosé au dessus du
désert du tennis nous allons y revenir
dans un instant mais d'abord une
cérémonie du souvenir et du
recueillement a eu lieu aujourd'hui à
l'aéroport de roissy rassemblant le
personnel de la compagnie ut à cérémonie
à la mémoire des passagers et des
membres de l'équipage philippe boisserie
stéphane poule à dieu georges renaud
jean pierre hennequin michel crézé 15
noms énumérés dans un silence de deuil
ceux de 15 confrères qu'un ami mort
subitement dans un ciel d'afrique
pilotes mécaniciens hôtesse de l'air de
la compagnie ut à ont voulu ainsi rendre
hommage à l'équipage du dc 10 victimes
du terrorisme
pas de banderole pas de slogan pas de
récriminations contre les mesures de
sécurité insuffisantes
l'heure était au recueillement à la
douleur après s'être rassemblés devant
le bâtiment réservé au personnel
navigant
tout le monde s'est retrouvé dans la
petite église de roissy pour une courte
cérémonie religieuse
dans le ciel le ballet des avions
continué nul doute que là aussi ont
partagé la même tristesse
l'anc est maintenant l'examen des boîtes
noires du dc-10 et de débris de la
carcasse de l'appareil ont permis d
aujourd'hui dès ce matin de dire avec
certitude que l'avion a explosé
au-dessus du désert du ténéré sans qu'à
aucun moment l'équipage n'ait signalé
auparavant un problème d'ordre technique
ou mécanique
la thèse de l'attentât est donc
quasiment certaine reste maintenant à
déterminer quelle organisation
terroriste l'a exécuté qu'il a
commandités
après une première revendication datant
de 48 heures de la djihad islamique
ce matin à beyrouth un mystérieux comité
de la résistance clandestine tchadienne
s'est fait connaître à son tour
explications d'hervé browsing certains
corps ont été identifiés mais la plupart
restent anonymes
pour l'heure on a pu retrouver seulement
les 171 victimes du dc 10 d'uta arrivée
à l'aéroport d'agadès les dépouilles
seront ensuite dirigés vers paris pour
le top 6
car désormais l'anc est entre dans une
phase décisive
les traces d'explosifs ont fortement
formellement été repérée sur les débris
du dc-10 le rapport des experts du
laboratoire central est arrivé en début
d'après midi à paris à présent
l'attentât contre l'avion du téat ne
fait plus aucun doute
il faudra encore plusieurs jours avant
de connaître la nature des substances
qui ont composé la bombe
une enquête préliminaire a été ordonnée
par le parquet de paris
ce sont bien les experts
l'antiterrorisme qui sont maintenant au
travail
premier point de leur enquête quelles
méthodes ont utilisé les poseurs de
bombes
c'est vrai que les similitudes avec
l'attentât de lockerbie en décembre 81 8
sont grandes
ce cockpit retrouvé lui aussi presque
intacte le temps de vol qui a précédé
l'explosion
mais pour autant les services français
se refuse à aller plus loin
surtout quant à l'identification de
l'éventuelle coupable à lockerbie les
policiers américains et anglais avait
accusé les palestiniens dissidents du
fplp d'armes et jibril et il ajouté
l'opération était commandité très
certainement par des factions iranien
mais aujourd'hui ce précédent n'est
qu'une piste parmi tant d'autres pour
les spécialistes français des
spécialistes qui n'ont toujours pas
tranché sur un point essentiel
l'explication de l'attentât se
trouve-t-elle
ici en afrique ou au proche-orient une
organisation jusque là inconnu baptisé
résistance quand dessine tchadienne
vient de revendiquer l'attentât depuis
beyrouth
les experts français affirment que la
capitale libanaise n'abrite aucun
opposant au régime d'hissène habré
cette revendication pourrait bien n'être
qu'un écran de fumée
alors la réponse se trouve t'elle du
côté de cette filière chiite libanaise
fortement présente en afrique ici en
côte d'ivoire ils sont près de cent
mille par exemple souvent commerçants
très implanté dans la société
certains sont liés au réseau pro iranien
hezbollah mais là encore les
spécialistes de l'antiterrorisme me font
remarquer si ces gens ont utilisé leur
présence sur le continent africain pour
régler leurs comptes avec la france
cela risque là bas de leur coûter très
cher le cyclone hugo est en train de
terminer son parcours dévastateur sur le
sol des etats-unis après avoir fait de
nouvelles victimes et provoqué
d'importants dégâts matériels sur la
côte dans l'état de caroline du sud
isabelle bechler charlton sur la côte de
caroline du sud avait déjà connu
l'ouragan au siècle dernier car c'est là
que la guerre de sécession avait éclaté
aujourd'hui les belles demeures sudistes
ont dû essuyer dugourd le cyclone et ses
rafales à 200 kilomètres/heure 12
personnes ont trouvé la mort quatre cent
mille sont privés d'électricité
de mémoire d'homme on n'avait jamais vu
une telle violence
j'en ai connu des tempêtes mais alors
comme celle là jamais on était paralysée
morts de peur pendant cyclo les dégâts
considérables aussi sur la base aérienne
de charlton les militaires de leur côté
patrouillait pour dissuader les pillages
au total le prix de la catastrophe est
estimé à près de 7 milliards de francs
c'est sur la zone côtière cougot a été
le plus féroce à 240 kilomètres de là
dans les terres ces bourrasques que
c'était calme et 140 km heure quand même
ce cyclone doit aller mourir en paix
elles signent en pennsylvanie puis vers
le canada son bilan total aujourd'hui
caraïbes plus états unis est de 35 morts
à la guadeloupe ravagé il ya une semaine
maintenant par le cyclone hugo le même
les pouvoirs publics ont commencé
aujourd'hui la distribution des subsides
financiers de première urgence au
sinistre en attendant dans le quartier
le plus pauvre de pointe à pitre est
bien la solidarité s'organise reportage
de nos envoyés spéciaux agnès poirier et
dominique merlet ces tôles ces bouts de
bois
c'est tout ce qu'ils possèdent c'est ce
qui leur sert de maison boissard le
ghetto de pointe à pitre
six mille personnes vivent là dans la
misère les guadeloupéens mais aussi
beaucoup de dominicains et haïtiens qui
ont fui leur île et préfère survivre là
dans la clandestinité à boissard la
drogue est en vente libre
et la fin du cyclone ils sont revenus et
ont voulu réparer
marie rose elle ne sait plus quoi faire
elle tenait une petite épicerie les au
plus fort du cyclone sa maison a glissé
dans le canal ces deux là ça nous allons
mais là avec des les éthiques liées à
mon fils et ma fille dormait avec les
usa fois je ne sais pas mais là la mise
à tomber dans l'étalagé par omar ici ça
pour moi c'est parti on a été à l'école
le soir dans les parties de les faire le
ventoux et lorsqu'on est venu avant a
retrouvé isolé tout ça sur les jambes
qui ont bouleversé la mise et chez des
parents le suppléant mieux comment
voulez vous la pêche y avait trois
vodkas flâne on est parti avec genève un
seul but mais j'ai mon fils mais sa
maison par une autre qui l'a jamais
certain
à boissard on s'organise comme sur toute
la zone touchée par le cyclone
la campagne de vaccination antitétanique
a commencé au dispensaire tenus par les
religieuses pas de panique
aucun début d'épidémie juste quelques
cas de dysenterie et de nombreuses
plaies qui s'infectent de temps en temps
des cartons de vêtements arrivent il est
plus des mains se serrent bon quand même
la toile et wayan volet ben la maison
tous les meubles les bouquets était dans
la maison emi c'est pas trop dur dans
les rues étroites de boissard les
ordures s'amoncellent
le service de désinfection six jours
après le cyclone est enfin passé l'eau a
été rétablie mais elle n'est pas potable
il faut la faire bouillir
quant à l'électricité il va falloir
attendre encore plusieurs semaines
alors tous les soirs à 6 heures quand la
nuit tombe
c'est le couvre-feu et 7e aux 1 et 2 à
sabathé l' iphone en a fait un bond pour
revoir rien tu es sétif et autres iphone
os que c'est à dire six à huit heures
c'est tout j'essaie accords et des va
faire le mieux pour nous
la mairie leur a demandé de s'inscrire
promettant qu'une aide lors seraient
accordés comme à tous les sinistrés de
l'île mais beaucoup n'osent pas faire la
démarche ils craignent que la mairie
n'achève le travail du cyclone qu'on les
met à la rue et qu'on détruit ce
quartier de misère leur quartier s'ils
ne s'agissait de minables malfrats qui
ont pris en otage pendant une semaine
une femme et ses deux enfants
heureusement sain et sauf on pourrait
dire que la nuit dernière
eh bien ces gangsters ont mis en scène
leur reddition selon un scénario qui
ressemble à s'y méprendre à celui des
séries amérique
le chef de bande s'est suicidé ses deux
complices se sont rendus au terme d'une
course poursuite qui s'est terminée en
haut d'une tour de liège
d'où ils ont commencé à disperser les
billets de la rançon versée
quelques heures auparavant soldes le
récit de nos envoyés spéciaux
bruno gex et jean-françois les pieds de
tenir walkman blessé d'une balle dans le
ventre
il est évacué sur une civière vers
l'hôpital de liège
edouard de l'est qui sort de l'immeuble
encadrées par les forces spéciales
d'intervention
philippe de leur ai déjà mon huitième
étage dans la cage d'escalier de ce
building a été découvert le corps sans
vie de deux l'ère philippe l'autopsié
qui a été pratiquée cette nuit à révéler
de façon formelle que le truand français
s'était donné la mort la cavale avait
commencé six heures plus tôt après la
libération hâtive des deux otages
19h hier selon un scénario préparé à
l'avance la police dépose la rançon
devant la villa de la famille joris une
ambulance va chercher les deux fillettes
gaël et françoise l'une après l'autre
20h30 la voiture de philippe delaire
démarre en trombe suivi par les
policiers
les ravisseurs prennent la direction de
liège ils libèrent leur dernier otage
marie madeleine je ris il change de
véhicules et s'arrête à droite au nord
de la ville dans cet immeuble de 28
étages où la police les attend 22h une
fusillade éclate c'est à ce moment là
que de l'air se serait suicidé radman
celui des blessés avec de l'équipe ils
parviennent à se réfugier sur le toit
d'où ils lancent les billets de la
rançon il est 22h30
trois quarts d'heure plus tard les deux
hommes acceptent de se rendre la chasse
à l'homme est terminée le cauchemar des
otages aura duré près d'une semaine dans
cette ville à un camp retranché que les
ravisseurs ont saccagé avant de fuir au
liban le général aoun chef des forces
armées chrétiennes a annoncé qu'il
acceptait donc le plan de paix arabe en
conséquence le cessez-le-feu est entrée
en application aujourd'hui même sur le
plan diplomatique le général a dû
accepter donc de renoncer à son idée de
bouter les syriens hors du pays après
six mois de combats acharnés l'essentiel
ce soit n'est-il pas pour autant que
tous les libanais croit à une petite
chance de paix en tout cas ils y croient
eux car des milliers de réfugiés ont
déjà décidé de regagner la capitale
beyrouth
valérie faune comme si les sens du tout
ces dernières signatures pour mettre fin
à leur exil les libéraux viennent par
milliers ils veulent croire à cette
nouvelle paix il aura fallu une semaine
d'intenses négociations pour que le
général aoun finissent par céder signer
le plan de paix arabe du triumvirat tu
algérie arabie saoudite et maroc soutenu
par la france et les etats unis face aux
syriens qui contrôlent la plus grande
partie de beyrouth et la plaine de la
bekaa accepté n'était pas chose facile
pour l'homme qui a déclenché le 14 mars
dernier la guerre de libération contre
l'occupation syrienne
une guerre qui a fait plus de mille
morts et près de 6000 blessés
est-ce que l'acceptation de ce plan de
paix arabe n'est pas en quelque sorte
une reddition je suis triste parce que
les sacrifices consentis pendant la
guerre de libération et les 6000
victimes andré pendant six mois n'ont
servi à rien le triumvirat rapport
proposait au général de michel la honte
le consentement ou le viol et la
préférée le consentement
ici la signer c'est dit il qu'il a reçu
l'assurance que les séries avons quitté
le pays
une façon de démontrer que la guerre n'a
pas été inutile mais le plan de paix
n'envisage pas le retrait des troupes
syriennes
premier résultat concret de ce plan
annoncé par l'émissaire lakhdar brahimi
entre en vigueur immédiate du
cessez-le-feu levée du blocus maritime
des ports chrétiens et réouverture de
l'aéroport de beyrouth pour l'instant
unanimement déclarés la trêve du liban
est loin d'être acquise autre conflit à
l'autre bout du monde au cambodge les
troupes vietnamiennes ont commencé
aujourd'hui leur retraite
vrai ou nouveaux faux départ la question
reste posée bien qu'un oeil ce soit
formellement engagé sur ce point sur le
terrain ce retrait vietnamiens ne règle
rien puisque aucun accord n'étant
intervenu entre les différentes factions
cambodgienne et bien c'est le vide
politique et même la reprise des combats
entre l'armée régulière cambodgienne et
les khmers rouges et reuben
démonstration de force de l'armée
cambodgienne sous les objectifs de la
presse internationale une armée
aujourd'hui
livrée à elle-même face aux khmers
rouges et aux autres mouvements de la
guérilla après dix ans de présence
vietnamienne hanoï poursuit le retrait
de ses troupes qui devrait être achevé
marque le premier ministre cambodgien
wiesen vient d'accepter le principe d'un
contrôle par l'onu de ces opérations
d'évacuation des vingt-six mille soldats
vietnamiens encore basée sur le
territoire cambodgien
cependant aucune solution politique
n'étant vous ses soldats sans parade
abandonne un pays au bord de la guerre
civile
les combats redoublent de violence sur
la frontière avec la thaïlande où les
positions gouvernementales sont pilonnés
par les khmers rouges
leur objectif prendre le contrôle d'une
ville en territoire cambodgien
afin de conforter leur position dans les
futures négociations
de source thaïlandaise on apprend que
les pourparlers de paix devrait
reprendre entre phnom penh et les
différents mouvements de la guérilla en
attendant la parole reste au canon
vingt-quatre heures après l'attentât
perpétré par des terroristes irlandais
de l'ira contre une caserne de l'armée
anglaise qui a fait 10 morts et bien les
britanniques cherchent à comprendre
pourquoi pourquoi un établissement
militaire était gardée par une compagnie
civile autrement dit pourquoi ces civils
gardez donc des soldes à londres
philippe harrouard l'ira avait prévenu
cette année 89 20e anniversaire de
l'installation des troupes britanniques
en irlande du nord serait marquée par
des actions contre l'armée voilà qui est
fait après plusieurs tentatives
infructueuses
preuve que la police est loin d'être
passif cependant l'organisation
terroriste c'est profiter des faiblesses
du dispositif de sécurité pour frapper
la caserne de guile est ce qu'on appelle
une cible molle
sauf tanguay la sécurité y est relax
parce que c'est une école de musique
ici les recrues sont plus des musiciens
que des soldats certes il y à un
entraînement militaire
mais ils n'ont pas d'armes et leur tâche
sera de se joindre aux sept fanfares des
royals malige qui sillonne le monde
adil les voisins ont tous dit qu'on
entrait comme dans un moulin
ce jeune homme la veille de l'attentât a
assisté à une soirée disco dans la
caserne le contrôle dit il était quasi
inexistant pour les poseurs de bombes ce
n'était pas difficile de pénétrer dans
les lieux
peut-être d'ailleurs lors de la soirée
disco la police en tout cas recherchent
une maison dans les environs qui a été
loué sans doute par le commando le
public a appris non sans surprise
qu'adil mais aussi dans d'autres
établissements militaires ce sont des
compagnies privées qui était chargé de
la sécurité
c'est plus économique disent les
autorités est aussi efficace qu'avec des
soldats ce qui est aujourd'hui très
contestée après l'attentât une fois de
plus on va revoir toutes les mesures de
sécurité dans les casernes en grande
bretagne et sur le continent en sachant
bien qu'une protection à 100% est
impossible mais ce qu'il faut avant tout
c'est laisser le moins de chances
possibles aux terroristes à l'étranger
une information importante encore mais
qui reste abstraite pour le moment
d'humains l'urss vient d'annoncer
qu'elle acceptait de négocier sur la
réduction des armements stratégiques
nucléaires avec les états unis
sans exiger au préalable que washington
renonce à son projet de guerre des
étoiles c'est à dire d'engins spatiaux
sophistiqué disposer au dessus de
l'amérique est capable d'anéantir les
missiles nucléaires soviétiques avant
qu'il n'arrive sur leurs sites en france
statu quo dans le conflit chez peugeot
le pdg jacques rey à qui jacques calvet
estime une fois encore qu'il ne peut
aller plus loin dans ses propositions
salariales il a été vivement critiquée
aujourd'hui pas le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste monsieur pierre mauroy
qui a déclaré nous en faisant référence
au parti socialiste nous acceptons de
changer vous aussi les patrons vous
devez changer
fin de citation voilà maintenant un
sujet de préoccupation qui concerne un
bon nombre de français l'endettement le
secrétaire d'état à la consommation
véronique neiertz va présenter un projet
de loi aux parlementaires pour essayer
de freiner la pelle des entreprises
spécialisées au crédit dont les
apparences de ce crédit sont parfois
trompeuses et bien tentant tout le monde
sait qu'il n'y a pas de vraie crédits
gratuits mais certains consommateurs se
laissent prendre et il faut parfois les
défendre contre eux mêmes c'est l'esprit
du projet en question en quête de marque
maison neuve et daniel lévy
on le sait il y a une limite à ne pas
dépasser en matière de crédit 30% des
ressources du foyer
pourtant l'envié parfois trop forte et
le vendeur très convaincant à la fin
j'avais tellement eu marre jusqu'à ses
oeuvres gecina et voilà je me suis mis
cinquante cinq mille francs sur le dos
va cinquante six mille francs pour une
cuisine aménagée c'est cher d'autant
qu'il faut payer le salon acheter à
crédit le loyer les charges aujourd'hui
avec un revenu équivalent au smic
eliane beauty regrette son acquisition
seulement qu'on marche me suis réveillé
en libye c'est pas possible pour être à
payer tout ça
vivre à crédit c'est prendre part au
rêve et tant pis si ce rêve et celui des
autres est allé offert par la publicité
des objets in achetable au comptant ce
qu'il faut absolument posséder comme
s'il faisait partie d'une panoplie celle
de la réussite
l'endettement et la face cachée de
l'individualisme et héroïque héroïque on
nous présente on nous présente toujours
l'homme qui réussit partout l'homme
sursis d'entreprise
l'homme qui réussit dans sa sexualité
l'homme qui réussit dans sa famille qui
réussit par évidemment plus on est dans
ce modèle de la réussite individualiste
plus évidemment tout ne peut pas être
bon partout et à la fin de l'année 1988
le volume du crédit aux particuliers
représentaient 1530 milliards de francs
c'est plus que le budget de l'état au
sein des ménages
il y à une frénésie de consommation
quand on sait plus quand on a le
sentiment de ne plus maîtriser son
avenir à court terme
je crois que ça provoque demander des
comportements qui nous paraissent
absolument incompréhensible mais il est
très difficile du point de vue
d'affaires fierté des gens de se dire je
vais revendre la maison par exemple
le surendettement est le résultat d'un
comportement qui échappe au rationnel un
incident et c'est la faillite
les trois quarts des dossiers examinés
par les tribunaux d'instance concernent
des dettes impayées
aucune de ces familles ne perçoit la
durée réelle ni le coût des dettes
qu'elles contractent elle achète
s'enfonçant chaque fois un peu plus dans
le crédit quitte à financer un
remboursement par un nouvel emprunt dès
lors on imagine mal une issue favorable
cette information encore en bref dup qui
s'est terminée tragiquement cet après
midi à marseille un vigile d'un grand
magasin a été tué et un autre grièvement
blessé par un malfaiteur qui a réussi à
prendre la fuite
après son rôle c'est un voyage inattendu
que je vous invite maintenant une preuve
que la politique d'ouverture de l'union
soviétique ne s'arrête pas à l'économie
m déborde largement sur le plan culturel
le metteur en scène français patrice
chéreau à la tête de sa troupe du
théâtre de nanterre joue en ce moment à
moscou hamlet patrice chéreau qui a
découvert que la capitale soviétique
était hanté par d'autres spect que ceux
du théâtre de shakespeare reportage de
michel ocelot vie s'y est pas terrible
patrice chéreau pour la première fois à
moscou avec sa percutante mise en scène
d' hamlet une tournée européenne qui
débute par la capitale russe une tournée
comme un besoin de se confronter au
regard des autres comme un besoin de les
découvrir
je trouve ça très émouvant d'être là je
trouve ça c'était d'abord parce que
c'est un pays ou une ville où il se
passe énormément de choses essentielles
pour nous tous je prends maintenant en
plus parce que c'est un pays où les gens
sont très amoureux du théâtre et
l'accueil fait au spectacle est
magnifique succès de ce spectacle ou
pour les moscovites la surprise joue à
plein comme avec ce cavalier sur scène
apparition réglé comme un ballet du
spectre du père d'hamlet le roi
assassiné
un succès dû à l'amour de la perfection
de patrice chéreau encore en répétition
à une heure de la représentation
de ma vie je ne révèle rien de semble je
suis bouleversée
ce serait formidable la lumière est ému
cinq ans brett c'est
scénographie c'était quelque chose
d'extraordinaire
un spectre hante à blaye celui du roi
assassiné
un spectre hante la place rouge celui de
l'ennemi le siècle qui est derrière moi
et beaucoup plus encombrant fut celui de
la mnef
à cet instant tout cas auquel beaucoup
de gens ont cru on a même moi même
d'ailleurs une époque et il est très
très encombrant ce sont comme refermer
la porte sur les fantômes
telle est la question
le sport maintenant qui est aussi
parfois shakespearien exemple
l'automobile avec la remontée d'alain
prost aux essais du grand prix du
portugal il partira demain dimanche en
deuxième ligne
parallèlement à cela le conflit au sein
de l'écurie mclaren honda est pour
l'instant au point mort alain prost
ayant décidé d'enterrer provisoirement
la hache de guerre et de ne plus se
plaindre du meilleur traitement accordé
à son coéquipier sénat depuis que
lui-même prost a décidé de passer la
saison prochaine chez ferrari codema le
casque jaune de senna une nouvelle fois
en tête le brésilien réaliser cet après
midi sa 10e pole position de la saison
sur cette course et la trente neuvième
de sa carrière
il partira donc en première ligne de ce
grand prix du portugal dont il est bien
sûr le grand favori favori même si les
deux ferrari ne sont pas très loin
derrière l'autrichien a réalisé le
deuxième meilleur temps devançant son
coéquipier nigel mansell de quelques
centièmes de seconde
quand alain prost il semble aujourd'hui
avoir retrouvé une voiture compétitive
hier il était encore pointé à 2 secondes
de senna moi je pense que j'aurai une
voiture pour gagner la course demain je
le crois encore vous nous dites ça ça
veut dire que les critiques avaient eu
lieu à monza c'est terminé tout ça alors
il ya un gentleman agrément qui est
passé avec votre équipe avec honda est
avec vous et apparemment tout marche
bien réparer une autre question pouvait
pas parler de ça
sentant le plus derrière les quatre
grands petite surprise avec l'excellente
cinquième place de pierluigi martini la
minardi partira en troisième ligne aux
côtés de la williams de patrese quant à
alex caffi il confirme ses précédents
résultats en devançant thierry bout de
scène
et puis ce résultat qui vient de tomber
à l'instant au championnat d'europe de
volley ball à stockholm la france vient
de battre l'allemagne de l'est 3 sets à
ce qui est certain c'est que nous ne
réagirons pas tous de la même façon
reportage qui va suivre mais les faits
sont là ils existent et va je crois la
peine d'être rapporté le grand hôtel
carlton de cannes pour attirer sa
clientèle haut de gamme vient de se
doter d'une suite de très très très
grand luxe à 35 mille francs la nuit
visite guidée par patrice de l'est et
jean françois georges bonjour vous faire
visiter la suite impériale du carotène à
l'intercontinental si vous l'aviez non
7e étage ascenseur privé la suite la
plus luxueuse de la côte d'azur
chaque pièce a une terrasse solarium de
l'ancien maire et maintenant je vais
vous faire découvrir pouvant
l'accueillir 1 800 personnes
et comme le salon la salle à manger a
également une terrasse solarium d'un an
sur n'ai rien ne manque à ce véritable
appartement 13 pièces y compris la
cuisine équipée 400 mètres carrés de
moquette épaisse de marbre reluisant
pour amateurs de luxe en fin de grand
luxe
je passe des étrangers de toutes
nationalités que ce soir américains
anglais au moyen-orient vous pensez à
louer à toute l'année ou seulement une
partie de l'année une première étude je
pense que nous allons louer déjà sept
l'année 1990 80 jours environ c'est
beaucoup c'est pas assez pour vivre
c'est 81 jours il faudrait allouer un
peu plus maintenant je vais vous faire
visiter la salle de bains de la chambre
principale en main hormis du brésil si
vous voulez bien sûr ici jacuzzi germes
ou de l'autre côté vous avez la douche
avec vapeur sur les côtés tout ça apple
de la suite impériale je trouve que
c'est merveilleux
sans oublier le fin du fin le téléphone
dans les wc et dans la chambre à coucher
une télévision escamotable par
télécommande pour vraiment ne pas se
fatiguer
la condition bien sûr d'avoir une envie
pressante de téléphoner et si vous
coucher au carlton cette nuit vous allez
vite bénéficier d'une réduction en effet
vous dormirez une heure de plus en effet
n'oubliez pas que nous repassons à
l'heure d'hiver demain dimanche à 3
heures du matin regardez bien sûr la
pendule et bien à 3 heures du matin vous
pourrez revenir en arrière d'une heure
il ne sera que 2 heures du matin
officiellement du monde ne tire c'est
maintenant voilà ce qu'il fallait jouer
cet après midi pour gagner
éventuellement une nuit au carlton de
cannes vous allez voir les résultats à
s'inscrire sur votre écran si vous ne
voyez pas que je voulais donner le 18 le
11 le 17 et vous gagnez 1068 francs où
je dois payer un acompte seulement pour
ce qui concerne le quarté + n'avait pas
encore là la somme pour passer la nuit
mais on y arrive presse vous ajoutez le
12 et vous gagnez 10 1654 francs et
vincenti voilà au lieu d'avoir les
treize pièces de la suite vous en aurez
que six mais en tout cas vous pourrez
toujours livre est donc cette ni aucun
jeune ne voilà juste après ce journal
vous retrouverez jose dans la pierre
pour les prévisions météo aux alentours
de 23 heures 20 philippe gassot pour les
toutes dernières informations en
attendant bien sûr
bonne soirée avec champs-elysées sur
antenne 2 bonsoir à demain 13h